what i have drawn here is a mass sitting
on a frictionless surface that is
attached to a spring that is attached to
the wall
and what we're going to do is we're
going to compress the spring we're going
to get the mass to position a right now
it's at position zero we're going to get
it to position a and then at time equals
zero we are going to let go and so you
can imagine what's going to happen
especially with this mass on a
frictionless surface it's going to
oscillate between position a and
position negative a and we have that
depicted right here on this position
versus time graph it'll start at
position a and then it will oscillate to
the left to position negative a and then
oscillate to the right position a again
on and on and on forever if we're
dealing with a world that is
frictionless like it's a frictional
surface and let's also assume no air
resistance so that is all very
interesting but what we want to think
about in this video is how that might
relate to energy
so given the information that i've just
given you let's start thinking about
elastic potential energy remember at
time equals zero the box is at position
a so our spring is compressed and we're
dealing with a box spring system so the
combined system of the box and the
spring and we're going to assume that
there is no added energy that's added to
or taken away from the system so right
at time zero when we have the spring
compressed that box spring system is
going to have some elastic potential
energy and so let's put that right over
there
and then what's going to happen when we
let go
well the box is going to be pushed by
the spring towards the left actually
it's going to be accelerated to the left
and right when the box crosses the x
position of zero which we see happens at
time equals one second all of our
potential energy is going to be
converted to kinetic energy and so our
potential energy is going to be right
over here
and then what happens is the box starts
getting decelerated by the spring and it
gets to position negative a well at
position negative a which we see happens
at time equals two seconds well then we
are back to having our maximum potential
energy again so we're back to having our
maximum potential energy at time equals
two seconds which is associated with
being at position negative a
and so you can see where this is going
at three seconds all of that potential
energy is back converted to kinetic
energy at four seconds we are back at
position a it's back into potential
energy again and so the graph of our
elastic potential energy is going to
look
something like this
it's going to look
something like this is a hand-drawn
version of it but you i think
get the general idea of what's going on
here notice it is not getting negative
and so it would look something like that
now what about kinetic energy well i've
already made some reference to it let's
think about how that would trend over
time
at time equal 0 when the box is at
position a right at that moment we
aren't going to have any kinetic energy
just yet but then the box is going to be
accelerated as that potential energy is
turned into kinetic energy and we are at
our maximum kinetic energy when the box
crosses position zero well the first
time it crosses position zero is at time
equals one second so we have our maximum
kinetic energy right over there
and then
when we get to time equals two our box
is at position negative a we no longer
for a moment we won't have any velocity
and our kinetic energy is gone and so
you can see how this is going we keep
switching between potential and kinetic
energy as we as the box keeps
oscillating between position a
and
position
position negative a once again this is
my hand drawn
depiction of it so that is our kinetic
energy now when we first introduced
ourselves to energy and the law of
conservation of energy we saw that hey
look if we are in a closed system and
there are no dissipative forces and
we're not adding energy or taking away
energy from that closed system and if
we're just dealing with mechanical
energy in this non and non-dissipative
forces well then mechanical energy
should be conserved if we say that the
total mechanical energy of the system e
is equal to our potential energy which
in this case is all elastic potential
energy
plus our kinetic energy this should be
constant and it is indeed the case if at
any point in time you were to add these
two curves up you would get something
that looks like this it would just be a
constant line and that would be the
graph of our mechanical potential energy
now an interesting question is what if
we did have dissipative forces what
would things look like then
well if we had dissipative forces say
friction or air resistance well then the
box might start at position a but then
it wouldn't get all the way to negative
a it might look something like this it
might start here but it might not get
all the way to negative a and then it
will get even not as far this time
and then it would get
and i'm trying to draw it as best as i
can and then it would get even not as
far that time and if we think about it
in terms of energy the total mechanical
energy would decrease where is it going
well it is being transformed into
thermal energy by the dissipative forces
of friction and air resistance so the
total energy would decrease and then
this would define the envelope for the
oscillations for the potential energy
and the kinetic energy so for example
the kinetic energy in that situation
would look like this
it would look
like
it would look like this
where the peaks are going to be bounded
by this total by this total mechanical
energy so i will leave you there
hopefully this gives you a sense of how
potential energy kinetic energy
especially when you're dealing with a
spring block system how they relate to
each other especially in relation to the
law of conservation of energy